nspcc has been given six hundred
thousand pounds by the government to
support its
whistleblowing helpline
but also a day after sweater Bradman
said that Pakistani men were
overrepresented in this abuse the nspcc
came out and said oh you can't say that
and that that risks that risks a blind
spot in our analysis of these gangs Etc
no the blind spot we've had has been
people ignoring Pakistani grooming gangs
that's where the real blind spot has
been now people are very alert
to other issues
the police have been
they've actually been pretty surely in
dealing with sex abuse across the
country but they've been especially bad
at dealing with these gangs that's where
the real blind spot has been happening
and I thought that was just an
unbelievable statement